[Music]
Carol Danver prodigal child of the Milky
Way Nick Fury my favorite oneeyed man of
intrigue how goes it out there you know
cold no air
[Applause]
space Captain Marvel the
annihilator you took everything from
me and now I'm returning the
favor what is happening to
me she's entangled our light based
Powers so we switch places whenever we
use
them strong strong Theory you can absorb
light
I can see it and Camala who's Cala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of I can
totally show you
[Music]
no
style she's t every planet we call
[Music]
home I would never choose to bring
anybody into this you are not the only
thing standing between this and the
universe oh my God we're a
team
higher
further
[Music]
faster
who's a good kitty
Goose oh my
God I can't can you I got
it Mr
snow after everything you've seen out
there in the
world what are the Hunger Games for
are
you are
you
coming
the The Hunger Games they to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice Your Role is to turn these
children into spectacles not
survivors we're
live smile it's why we have
teeth imagine it was your name that they
pulled I just want to know that somebody
still cared about me that I was still a
value welcome to the capital you look
like you shouldn't be here I shouldn't
but I'm your Mentor a
rebel I am going to get you out of here
you want to protect
people then it's essential to accept
what human beings
are and what it takes to control them
let's see you use that famous snow
charm you seem like a good man Corina
snow I have seen what war does to
people fued with a turve becoming
prey see how quickly we become
Predator I want my enemies to see a
rainbow of
Destruction engulfing the
world come moners all of
you good luck with that poor little song
bird where is
she it's mystery and Mysteries have a
way of driving people
mad Mr snow let me ask you one final
time what are the Hunger Games for
the
Hanging
[Music]
Tree it's the things we love most that
destroy
[Applause]
us
[Music]
was it
a
[Music]
speee
foreign
[Music]
Goa
this world is beyond
cruelty you've been fighting the hinin
for decades my family's been fighting
them for
centuries and they were
massacred alongside my father your
father didn't believe in Revenge
we believe in fman let me fight beside
you
reload he said that I got
that
thanks I won't be fighting for him I'm
fighting for my
people you young
pop do you believe in
Paul that are
science the prophet why is that a bad
thing use
it because all my Visions lead to
horror because you lose control because
I gain
it Johnny do you believe in me
Paul trates is still
alive deal with this
Prophet show me you
are your
son was a weak man
ru's back from the
dead now do what must be
done we gave them something to hope for
that's not
hope I will love you as long as I
breathe this prophecy is how they
enslave
us it's not a prophecy it's a story I
don't care what you believe I believe
I am Paul M Diva
Tres Duke of
[Music]
baracus he who can destroy a thing has
the real control of
[Music]
it
4 years ago I was basically
unemployed a Wanderer with no
home but now I'm a husband and a
father and I wouldn't have it any other
way I'm know how you do it pops my job
was a little less stressful than
yours
oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the king
of
[Music]
Atlantis half a billion people from
every known species in the sea call this
place
home but that doesn't mean they all like
me I'm going to kill Aquaman and destroy
everything he holds
dear I'm going to murder his
family and burn his kingdom to ass
he must be stopped or a global meltdown
is
imminent I think I know someone I might
bu to help
us you look
rough good job little brother high five
do not call me
brother I cannot believe you let this
happen yeah well I hate his job true
king built Bridges right
true king builds
Bridges we need to find Manta he's
different now he's stronger than
before it's the black
Trion during King alin's time there were
Seven
Kingdoms he trid it was a curse upon
them
all the trid and start magic is
spreading he means to end the bloodline
[Music]
I don't know what lies ahead but we
can't leave our children a world without
hope you're not as bad at this as you
think if you lead the Seven Kingdoms
will
[Music]
follow
etaa 5 minutes to the war zone we
must F Soldier
[Music]
no
go
[Music]
when the war
started they protected
me took better care of me than humans
would
have they not people
Maya it's just
programming 10 years ago today the
artificial intelligence created to
protect us detonated a nuclear warhead
in Los
Angeles this is a fight for our very
existence Sergeant Taylor we are this
close to winning the
war but the AI are developing a super
weapon retrieve
it or they win come back to
[Music]
you did you locate the weapon yeah it's
just a kit
are you going to heaven
no you got to be a good person to go to
heaven then we're the same we can't go
to heaven cuz you're not
good and I'm not a
person do you have any idea with that
thing is she looks like a little girl
now but she's
growing Whoever has that kid wins the
war who side you want
huh
come
back what do you want sweetie for robots
to be
free oh we don't have that in the fridge
how about ice
cream
leave
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
EX
h
f
[Music]
[Applause]
Jonas we need your
help we're detecting increased aaric
activity 25,000 ft deep in the
trench it's an ancient ecosystem
Untouched by man whatever is down there
is trying to make its way to the
surface this is a bad idea yeah just a
little
[Music]
bit julas we've got
company that's the biggest night I've
ever seen biggest me anyone's everever
seen that's the apex predator
everybody make get to the station you
can make it keep
going three massive Megs and who knows
what else have escaped the
breach I just hope it goes better than
last
time what happened last
time you don't want to
know you no go go you never seen this
before they hunted it back
you can relax this place me proof I mean
Jonas was always afraid of this but I
was also
[Music]
thinking
you
you ooh
barracuda
H expecting anyone I need to have an
intimate understanding of your marriage
the good and the
bad I promise it's confidential is
between you and me do you feel happy
here of course I'm happy here aren you
do you feel you know how she would react
in every every
situation I've always had this fantasy
that there's something else out there
for
[Music]
me do you want to live mundane lives or
do you want to be part of something
special and unique you've been selected
to live up there okay you're wasting
your time cuz we haven't even been on an
airplane sheated it I should I should
clarify I'm talking about you here
junior only
you
[Music]
we're going to ensure hen has company
while you're
away we're going to replace
[Music]
you I don't want a robot living with my
wife do you really want to leave her
here all alone day after day he doesn't
really see me
anymore maybe I shouldn't be telling you
this
jior I encourage you to use this
opportunity to act on your
instincts whatever we decide we'll be
together
[Music]
[Applause]
my son never show
Mercy they are
pray we
a
Predators Bo your mother is
dead she died because you sent her away
she was weak sick in her mind you know
my business Yes
master power is about
strength if you show
weakness you will give our enemies an
opening shoot
shoot
he is weak like his mother leave
him what happened that
day I stared death in the face and for
the first time I saw my true
self tell me about this
Hunter they say he uses a connection
with animals to track his prey
once you're on his
list there's only one way off there's
six of us there only one of you there's
six of you
[Music]
now why do you hunt my father puts evil
into the
world I take it
[Music]
out I think you have some kind of Honor
you are exactly like our father just
another man hunting for a
trophy we're
murderers is not what he taught
us you don't get to do that to me
anymore Mr
tlin Mr
tlan where's Mr tlin oh you're standing
in
him you're a goddamn lunatic oh you just
figure that out
now there is an animal in
janas don't you want to know why they
call me the
Rhino for centuries Our Kind has stayed
hidden on
Earth but Darkness has found us
again
prime this is about the fate of all
living
things
Unicron is
[Music]
coming it
won
back up Oh I thought we were
boys you want it come and get it you
brought a human here I'm nobody I ain't
even see nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now think you hold the L
you haven't
the
stop this is not our
war Optimus we must trust each other to
protects the home we all
share how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a
planet
stop in the
end everything you cared
for will be
consumed maybe there's another way to
save our
home you've never faced anything like
this let them
come
[Music]
yo Noah Take the
Wheel
baby all I needed was I love you
G have you guys taken the test yeah 3
years ago we were positive felt like a
weight had been
lifted I founded this institute to take
the risk out of love no more uncertainty
no more wondering if you've chosen the
right partner no more divorce we were
the first to build the machines to
conduct the test to make the bond of
love
stronger I really want to work
here a lot of famous people study there
really like who Ginger Spice she's my
favorite I
know so you'll be shadowing air he's
already one of our most successful
instructors was the one thing you love
most about Maria take your time I love
her
hair it's soft it's nice answer it's
nice the truth is we're all achingly
lonely and we're endlessly searching for
ways to fill that void I asked you
something why do you work at The
Institute maybe you understand love a
little
better I really want to learn how the
exercises help you connect why are we
doing this I thought it'd be fun it's
just messy that's all
I think it's normal to get into a bit of
a routine I think relationship should be
worked on every day oh sorry sorry I was
wondering if it was possible that one
person could be in love with two people
at the same time it's a biological
impossibility yeah that's what I thought
too I need to tell you
something
[Music]
oh I ever
knew only
you okay I want to fly let's do
this
yeah
you got to force it to come out what are
you you're a genius I know what' I say
no
wa did you know what was going to
happened to my brother when you stuck
him with this world destroying
thing it's called the
Scarab I had no idea it would activate
it has to choose you give me that so how
do we get it to unchoose me
post acquired who said that systems
chapter 3 okay it's going to be
okay baby I was down but they see
baby overacting
overreacting you me when I hit you with
that you know you know threat
approaching engaging po protection
like and when we get I'm do like a
threat eliminated sorry about
that are they trying to steal away cut
it out cut it out what do you think the
government is going to do when they
figure out that some kid has this
military TCH it down it down we are
going to change the world with the power
of the Scarab it belongs to me
out
way oh he's
pissed listen to me up tail liit you got
the r my God I'm nobody I swear I down
they see I'm Ming now baby the world is
a place to protect I have an Arsenal at
my disposal anything please watch and
learn Kime wa whatever you can
imagine I can create yeah that's more
like
it
yeah that love you feel for your family
makes you weak you're wrong I my family
that's what makes me
strong oh I forgot how bad it
looks Target the
family sorry my mom fin you are a
superhero
Kon y take shots y aim up
who you're the Blue Beetle that could
use that Arsenal right about now God you
never ask hell yeah they me try to away
on butst it down butst it down N I
advise me back
away I was down but they see I'm
M we have a very important mission for
tonight we must use
stealth and cunning to infiltrate the
human world and
retrieve
Gogurt go okay Batman dude what I'm just
trying to Hype you guys up let's go from
Seth Rogan comes a movie that crushes
for absolutely every
age amazing insane all right tell me
more it's effortlessly cool and Visually
stunning it's the most fun you'll have
at the movies this
year that seems very dangerous be danger
for
actually I eat pizza with bits of
waffles on
it with the funniest cast ever assembled
surprise enough oh man you can't stop us
look we're the only ones who can do
this I'm awesome we're brothers we fight
together we're just getting started
[Music]
yes yeah she sounded like a leader I do
oh I do oh I sound like such a leader
and you ruined it Ninja
Turtles remember don't let any human see
you
hey exclusively in movie theaters August
2nd get your tickets
now
hello Joe
where let's discuss your new job what
job I got a wife she's pregnant please
let me
go at Mard your work consists of pushing
the
mill failure to meet your daily quota
will result in a
punishment the employee with the fewest
points will be
[Applause]
terminated when do I go
home you are well on your
[Applause]
way oh
you still don't believe the rules
apply to
you perhaps you would respond to other
incentives you took everything from me
what is this you're still asking
questions walk through the door prepare
your mind for a transformative
experience by
Mard you're a crucial part of our team
for
[Music]
life
fore
spe
[Music]
for
Fore
fore
m
[Music]
[Applause]
fore
I think that we ought to change our town
slogan a great place to call home is
confusing I suggest a great place to
refer to as home we need a crosswalk on
Trent Avenue between Frost and alany and
also oh my UFO is crashed my backyard
has taken out my aelas and destroyed my
bird bath when you talk like that it
makes them all take us less
seriously did you just say
UFO good Christ what is that you
remember the spaceship this is the
little man who came out of it he's got
to be a secret don't tell
anybody can't touch him she shouldn't
know we got to trust her there's nothing
else we can do we could kill her kill me
you can't kill me I'll kill you that's
what I'll do guys stop it you think we
can call call him Jewels he's no Jewels
he's more of a Gary your dad was in here
earlier he said he was buying apples for
an alien like any legal aliens thank you
for the picture he hands them to me all
the time maybe he's trying to tell you
something dad come on I'm worried what
you have said has not been normal I'm
okay how can you say that when you're
buying apples for an
alien the government is searching for
the security satellite that crashed any
moment we waste is a moment they can
discover him you see seen the movies you
know what happens to these guys when
they fall to
Earth will
break Jules has come to mean quite a bit
to
us it's about Dad buying apples for an
alien Das security open the door they're
coming bu for hanging out together we
get along pretty well we're so thankful
for
you there you got
me we will break the
sky what
the you know you really captured his
Essence maybe his face could use a
little more detail
though like a photograph I'm Adam Chloe
1 2
3 sure you're not going to make fun of
it show me all
right oh my
God this might be the nicest thing
anyone's ever done for
[Music]
me you have 62 viewers and $300 total do
you
[Music]
real that you they don't have love in
their culture they find romantic stuff
super exotic and
interesting they watch you go on
Dat family dinner is one of our most
cherished human rituals do you have to
do this right now Chloe you're not
supposed to talk about the broadcast on
the broadcast Flo
in hey would you keep that out of
my line of sight why don't you keep your
out of our line of sight you didn't
invent courtship broadcast
it has recently become obvious you
are deceiving your viewers what
deceiving the title of your broadcast is
Adam and Chloe in love and yet you are
not in
love I want you to repay all funds you
have received wait we've already spent
everything we made just to live then I
will take you to court and your families
will be in debt for approximately six
Generations do you want me to cut that
for you
where is the nearest
restaurant no part of my body can make
that noise it's well it certainly won't
if you don't
try we can get that love back romantic
love is the most poetic of all human
love modes it should never be faked I'm
just like any other person I want to
grow up and fall in love and be swept
off my
feet we've lost a lot since you guys
came here
but we've overcome a lot
[Music]
too